some span the stars some
pound the pavement and some work outside
of reality altogether
but all of these superhero teams shared
one thing in common they'd be right at
home on the silver screen
these are the dc teams we'd like to see
in the dc
eu sometimes known as the international
club of heroes the batman of all nations
debuted back in 1955.
in detective comics number 215 the
legend of batman has spread so widely
across the world that imitators have
emerged
and everywhere from argentina to italy
the knight
and the squire clean up crime in england
the gaucho rides through the streets of
argentina
protecting them from vicious criminals
the musketeer takes down parisian
nerdwells in a plumed chapeau this
is straight up silver aged comic book
story stuff
right down to the night and squires
horse-shaped motorcycles
you might think this would be a hard
sell for modern audiences
but the batman of all nations popped up
in 2007's batman number 667
and the concept is as fresh today as it
was the year it made its debut
with just a little fine tuning the idea
of batman styled vigilantes the world
over would fit
smoothly into the dc universe the dc
eu's world is a highly interconnected
one
with its modern day global conversation
moving at the light speed pace of social
media
in fact it might be stranger to imagine
a world where there
aren't batman imitators bring on the
batman from every corner of the globe
and let them redefine their group once
more this time
for dc's movie fans just don't invite
this guy
what gives you the right what's the
difference between you and me
i'm not wearing hockey pads
not every incarnation of the teen titans
has been a rousing success
but every single one has at least been
pretty interesting
the very first lineup referred to in
earnest as the fab foursome
hey it was the 60s you'd have loved it
at the time
the soap opera melodrama that was the
1980s new
teen titans who doesn't want their super
powered teenagers served with the sight
of angst romance and betrayal
and then there's the 2003 cartoon you
can bet
any money that an entire generation has
that theme song
permanently stuck in their heads most
recently
is the wacky wonderland that is teen
titans go
which has been running for an impressive
seven years now the point
is the teen titans are arguably one of
the best ideas dc has ever had
every lineup sizzles with storytelling
possibility
and it's a big help that the titans are
also already familiar property to many
fans
what with the last two decades worth of
smash hit cartoons in the dc universe
original series
so why not just go ahead and bring that
goodwill into the dc eu
and hey if nothing else who doesn't want
to see the titans try to explain why a
t-shaped tower isn't a disastrous idea
to robert pattinson's steely-eyed batman
originally the seven soldiers were a
golden age super team who took on the
axis in world war ii
then in 2005 writer grant morrison and a
roster of artists revamped the team into
something entirely different
and genuinely wonderful to boot seven
soldiers of victory chronicles
seven reluctant second string heroes
strange journey to coming together as a
team to fight the fiendish
shida an earth-inhabiting race of the
far future
what ultimately makes the story so
tremendously unique is its format
the series consists of two bookend
issues and between them
seven four-issue character-specific arcs
though every hero fights the shita they
do so separately
even in the climactic final battle they
can't really comprehend the larger
picture of what they are doing
in the end the seven soldiers are a team
who aren't
in fact much of a team at all this is a
balancing act of a book and one that
would admittedly
challenge any filmmaker no matter how
skilled they may be
but the comic pulled it off proving how
great the reward is for taking on the
risk of the premise
and a movie could succeed in much the
same way
it helps that the seven soldiers include
some of dc's most colorful characters
like zatanna and mr miracle they're all
a little weird
being rooted in their own particular
corners of the dc universe
swept up in dramas utterly unknown to
everyone else in the story
combining their unique paths into one
complete
satisfying big screen arc would
definitely be a challenge
but one that would be well worth
undertaking
the zoo crew is a band of
anthropomorphic animals from earth sea
a parallel planet home to places like
mew orleans
and pigsburg that'll do pig
that'll do the team's leader
is captain carrot known to most as mild
maynard
roger a humble cartoonist toiling away
in
new york city then superman crashed into
his reality and accidentally
irradiated the carrots growing in
roger's window box
one bite later and roger was bunny
hopping his way across the city
hearing noises from miles away and
discovering he had the strength
of a whole warren's worth of rabbits the
zoo crew
ended up being dc's last funny animal
property
but boy did they make it count and sure
you might not think such a wacky
childlike group has a place in the dc eu
but remember this it can get weirder
i just wash my hands that's why they're
wet
no other reason just as into the spider
verse introduced audiences to the idea
of using cartoon
physics as actual superpowers so too
have captain carrot and his furry
friends enjoyed a long history of
turning their slapstick toughness into a
tremendous advantage
take the events of the entirely straight
faced the multiversity series
in which carrot is plucked from his own
universe to fight in a far more serious
one
beside heroes from more typical dc
domains
while they get burned cut and crushed he
is merely flattened into a coin
and springs back up again try that on
for size steppenwolf
the fourth world is one of the best
parts of the dc
mythos it's high drama psychedelic
science fiction
and pop mythology all rolled up in jack
kirby's techno fantasy aesthetic
characters like darkseid and mr miracle
have gone on to figure
ensearing post-modern family dramas and
vast interstellar sagas alike
luckily the fourth world's characters
are already set to be part of the dceu
in the new gods movie directed by ava
duvernay
but it's all pomp and circumstance when
it comes to the denizens of apocalypse
and new genesis
enter the forever people the flower
children from beyond the stars
bottom line there is nothing subtle
about the forever people
they spend their immortal lives zooming
over the electron road in their mother
box-powered super cycle
they have names like big bear beautiful
dreamer and mark moonrider
and they dress like they were way laid
at a power rangers convention on their
way to coachella
in a superhero landscape that tends
toward stainless steel and desaturation
the forever people could be a heady
breath of fresh air
telling a genuinely universal teenage
superhero story
they're young they're invincible and
they're all tangled up in the wars and
triumphs of the adults in their lives
it's a tale as old as time except for
the cosmic motorbike that is
is there any super team more beloved
than the justice league
these guys are to comic books what apple
pie is to pastry
booyah but justice league international
is not exactly the team you picture
when that iconic squad of superheroes
comes to mind
assembled in the wake of crisis on
infinite earths
the justice league international
couldn't really get a hold of superman
wonder woman or the flash they're
basically the b side of justice leagues
batman's there but he's practically
marooned in a sea of lesser known heroes
like
blue beetle dr fate and black canary
what results is a zany delight the
tension among these mismatched team
members is palpable
and the series unflappable sense of
humor remains a breath of fresh air
jli blends comedy with genuine heroics
and keeps both parts all the more fresh
by doing so
the dc eu has struggled with dour
po-fascidness in the past
so why not inject it with a little
laughter
trouble's afoot in the dc universe but
superman batman and wonder woman are
busy
so what's a terrified bystander to do
why
call the hero hotline of course
available 24 hours a day
the hero hotline will dispatch one of
its many qualified super associates to
take care of whatever you need
run by the mysterious coordinator the
hotline's heroes include
luminaries such as microwavable
zeep the living sponge and marie a
psychic turtle
sporting a truly adorable helmet as you
might have guessed
the heroes of the hotline are not
exactly the dc universe's
premier good guys but what a concept
for one the hero hotline is unbashably
corporate
offering a unique look at how a world
with superheroes might actually function
and though the hotline's roster isn't
exactly a-list
it's hard not to fall in love with them
microwave a bell
juggles inexact bus schedules alongside
her scientific exploits
mr muscle constantly changes his name
and stretch lives life with stretching
powers that never stop working
meaning he typically looks like a wad of
thoroughly chewed gum
this could easily be the dceu's
guardians of the galaxy moment
and would provide a fascinating new
perspective on superhero storytelling
the newsboy legion began in the golden
age as a group of orphans living in
metropolis's notorious slums
they're a scrappy rambunctious gang who
slinged papers and managed to get into
all sorts of thrilling trouble
going by nicknames like big words and
scrappy years later
they were reintroduced and mixed up in
the more scientific corners of the dc
universe
leading to a whole lot of stories about
newsboy legion clones getting involved
in all
different corners of the dc universe
they are in short
the most classic of comic book
inventions a pretty simple concept made
wildly weird
by continuity reinvention and science so
advanced as to border on magic
the dc eu has a ton of options to pursue
here
if they ever wanted to introduce the
newsboy legion they could always go
classic
after all who doesn't like newsies but
the newsboy legion's involvement with
the fourth world and government cloning
has been part of their story for just as
long as their g-whiz golden years
that's not even the end of it though
young justice outsiders
recently reimagined the legion as
composed of news girls
who stream from their phones instead of
slinging papers
audiences could fall in love with any of
these takes whether decidedly old school
or totally new it isn't exactly accurate
to say that the royal flesh gang have
worn many hats over the course of their
decades long history
they have always maintained their
playing card theme for example
they've always been bad guys and they've
always favored a sleek aesthetic
but within those parameters the
portrayals of this particular team have
varied
wildly over the years the royal flush
gang have been taken over by the joker
dabbled in mind control and been
revealed as a multi-generational
operation perpetuated by
one seriously villainous family
there's one take that the dceu should
pay particular attention to however
the royal flush gang as portrayed on
justice league
unlimited and one of the most affecting
scenes of the series
it is revealed that this incarnation of
the team was created by ace
a psychic teenager who has warped
innocent bystanders into filling out the
gang's ranks
batman is sent in to kill her before she
breaks reality
entirely but all ace wants is for
someone to listen to her
batman does and holds her hand until she
passes away naturally
a revamp of the gang with this take on
ace at its core
is practically begging to be put on the
big screen
her story confronts dc's heroes with
some genuinely hard truths
while complicating the villains around
her and for all that subversion
it's a choice that still allows for all
the stylish fun of classic gang
interpretations
as far as villains go the royal flush
gang is a winning hand
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the dc eu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one